[Music]
next guest is a very talented Australian
comedian who could be seen Wednesday at
the Libero Theatre in Santa Barbara and
at the Balboa theater in San Diego this
Thursday please welcome back to our
program the very talented Tim Minchin
[Music]
clock my people rang me up a couple of
weeks ago yeah I've got people and a
phone and a grasp on the passage of time
before they rang me up said Tim do you
want to go on Conan's show they want you
to sing a song maybe it'll be fine fine
fine but the problem with my particular
mover this have half my songs of five
minutes an over and they say on USA TV
that you will switch off if you go past
3:00 and a lot of my songs have a bit of
bad language which causes viewers untold
anguish I'm told your tolerance for
smart does not extend beyond the Golden
Girls and two and a Half Men
and so ah need a song that only goes to
three minutes without no boobs or
blasphemy in a charming little baby that
won't raise the rates of the hearts of
the people in the pious states I need a
song with the car senators without no
nasty Carson and the curse on I'm a
little too lewd and a little too long I
got around seven three-minute song and
they said remain the boy the music is
loud making and simply self-indulgent to
take it passed three minutes work man
the more the music is like lovemaking
everybody loves a penis but legs must
have Halima so you meet a song that only
goes three minutes without not
photography or politics and a little
less rude and more concise just be
yourself but brief and nice 300 beats at
100 beats a minute with the nice clean
jokes and a hoedown in and I'm a little
verbose and a little bit wrong I gotta
rocks ever clean livin 3-minute song and
even in the bridge I won't be lyrically
adventurous conceptually contentious or
racially or fanciest and I won't make
double entendre z' at the expense of
that Chinese for China is a country that
can bring me to my knees for China
vagina vagina vagina
is a country that will bring me to my
knees
alright ladies you have periods we get
it ha ha ha 2 3 4 skin I need a little
happy clappy country song nice and
repetitive but not too long boring
enough but not too bored with a key
change here to prevent me snoring I need
a song that only goes three minutes
without no McGarity evolvers in it you
don't get lost by lingering but I better
get a giggle with the finger ring
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean a sauna costs no offense so I can
block more tickets and my concerts in
the hope that the network sticks me on a
late night show or a nice sitcom you've
got a box and I wanna be in and
apparently you'll only watch for three
minutes
don't mind me I'll be done in three
you